it's Donald Trump lying about having
been tested for coronavirus and testing
negative now I'm not suggesting Trump
didn't test negative although it
wouldn't surprise me that if Trump had
tested positive they simply wouldn't
tell us but the timing and especially
Donald Trump's very weird answer
yesterday when he was asked about what
it was like to be tested it all sounds
very strange and I don't know that
Donald Trump was actually tested so
let's go through it first starting with
the question yesterday during Trump's
coronavirus press conference Trump's
first answer about the timing and
results of his test you had your own a
virus test Friday night though the White
House doctor's office put out a
statement around midnight Friday saying
that no test was indicated so when
exactly was your test administered oh I
had my test I was late Friday night and
the reason I did it was because the I
had no symptoms whatsoever so the doctor
said you have no symptoms so we don't
see any reason but when I did the press
conference and fight everybody was going
crazy did you do the test did you do the
test so very late on Friday night I did
the test and he may have put out or the
doctor may have put out something at a I
don't know what time the letter went out
maybe it was put up by somebody else but
the results came back I believe the
following day and we tested negative
question top of the White House doctor's
office a test wasn't indicated
employment you hadn't had one when in
fact you had well I told them that and I
went totally by what they said the
doctors more than one they said you
don't have any of the symptoms they
checked what you're supposed to check
and that I didn't have symptoms but I
did it I did a test late on Friday night
and it came back probably 24 hours later
or something they sent it to the labs
came back so understand the timeline
that Trump is suggesting here combined
with what we know Friday at 3:30 Trump
was asked during his press conference
about being tested and he said I have no
symptoms I don't need to be tested but
maybe someday I will be Friday evening
the White House said Trump doesn't need
to be tested but then Trump now claims
that late on Friday he was tested for
coronavirus if the White House puts out
a statement saying nobody worried Trump
doesn't even need testing why would he
have been tested
basically at the exact same time that
the White House was putting out that
statement and then Trump claims that
Saturday evening so fewer than 24 hours
from when he was supposedly tested he
got a negative test result for
coronavirus so the question is a good
one if at 3:00 p.m. you said no symptoms
no need for a test if at night a doctor
said no symptoms no need for a test
why were you immediately tested and then
there's also the question of tests are
taking longer than 20 hours or 18 hours
now of course maybe when it's the
president they fast-track it we don't
know but they said that they are hopeful
someday we will get to 24 hour
turnaround on tests we're not there yet
at this point in time if the test was
done very late Friday as Trump says and
then early on Saturday evening the
results were already announced that is
way less than the 48 to 72 hour range
that is typically the one that's also
weird but then we get to the real
whopper and this is this is what Fermi
suggested this guy's not been tested
Trump was asked about the test and the
test requires a swab to be inserted
pretty deeply into the nose to get to
the throat it's not comfortable
most people gag tear up Koff etc which
is why the people doing the tests have
to be in full medical protective gear
and Trump responds in a way where it
doesn't seem like he knows how the test
is done and so he says something very
vague to avoid saying something that is
known to be untrue about the test itself
check it out and let me know what you
think nah not something I want to do
everyday I can tell you that it's a you
know it's a little bit of a it's a
little bit of good doctors in the White
House but it's a test it's a test it's a
medical test nothing Pleasant about it
it's a test it's a medical test and I
wouldn't you know recommend it's not
something I would want to do again does
this sound to anybody else like a
completely fabricated story that he made
up completely on the spot so let me know
what you think do you think Trump is
lying about having been tested at all do
you think Trump is lying about the
negative result if you said to me is the
lie about the result or is the lie about
being tested
I think the lies about being tested
not-not-not about the result although I
do think they would likely lie about the
result as well let me know what you
think I don't know
check out the excellent YouTube channel
we're partnering up with called up flip
you can get there at david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right
underneath this video make sure you
subscribe while you are there up flip is
a youtube channel that looks at
entrepreneurship in a very interesting
way their content looks at small
businesses what makes them successful
each video you get to meet a new
entrepreneur get a behind-the-scenes
look at their daily grind learn their
philosophy learn their business as a
business owner myself as someone with an
MBA I love watching the content there's
a ton of really useful insight to come
away with from every episode I love
hearing what the entrepreneurs share you
get practical advice they talk about
outside the box strategies and even if
you don't own a small business yourself
I think you'd be fascinated by the
content on up flip perfect for people
who like shows like Shark Tank and that
sort of thing get to the up flip YouTube
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is underneath the
video they're friends of the david
pakman show definitely make sure to
subscribe to their channel click that
bell icon on their page so you'll be
notified whenever they upload a new
video